we have a call in from from arisha
ideally when you start your business
you're going to have a clear set of your
core values I'm wondering though if
you've ever navigated not necessarily
when your values change but when they
refine and when they focus and what I'm
thinking about specifically as an
example is like you know the oprah
winfrey show it started out doing a lot
of kind of shocked TV and more
controversial tabloid topics and then
it's at some point right in the process
she had a value that just refined and
she's like I'm not going to do any more
shock TV I want to only focus on content
that will bring light into people's
lives but there's a transition in that
process that I am wondering um if you
can speak to when you know when you are
personally experiencing that maybe
change in conviction how do you
transition in a way that not only just
honors that change in yourself but like
honors your customers honors your team
that's pretty much my question so what
I'd say mission is is fundamentally
number one is typically I'd say most
businesses I look out there have the
same core values when they start is when
they're 10 years old 15 years old 20
years old and the core values around you
know we call out integrity customers
first they're never going to change what
the subtle nuance is of what problem
you're solving for customers or why
you're not going to ball out a part for
the customers or product innovation
that's going to changing the time and we
you know I'm just totally crazy I
challenge myself the team one of our
balances around sort of um sort of
revolutionized in the business for our
customers so we should never sit still
we should never be happy with the status
quo but the core values never change um
and I think it's interesting I I just
interviewed someone a senior role as say
age and the other the other company he
was interviewed by content in the name
is probably unfair but it was a tobacco
company and I just said well how come
you kind of interview with us where
we're really passionate about our values
and our integrity and then you're
interviewing the tobacco come you know I
you know people want to go and kill
themselves as their choice and I respect
that however where you going to spend to
that you know when you get a work when
you're an entrepreneur you spend in 230
of conscious life hope through people
you love colleagues you respect
customers that you're going to make
raving fans and you're going to make a
difference to the world and I think I do
think there for you know so call out i
think the Millennials guys like you a
much more conscious of that moral
compass and i think sadly in the past
people have compromised their moral
compass and and ended up working in
companies who had no heart so I I don't
from a company point of view from the
entrepreneurs point of view I'd really
advise you that establish things that
will last the test of time in terms of
um and then build them out yeah Brandon
around and have recruitment when you do
you know sit down and have reviews you
call them out their part they become
part of what you are and then it and
then as the market change the
opportunity changes as you evolve and
you kind of grew up then you can take a
bunch of wherever you sit in that but
the core bunny is always probably stay
yeah to answer that question about Oprah
you know as you see Oprah evolved I feel
like she just became more and more
self-confident and more and more
trusting and who she was and not trying
to be what other people wanted her to be
right so you can do this shock and awe
campaign and and you know boyfriend
stabs girlfriend on air or whatever I'm
gonna get you some ratings but I feel
like that wasn't truly her if you watch
Oprah she's all about heart right like
Oprah really cares about people
genuinely like he lit it radiates but
her earlier stuff
it's very formal almost corporate you
know it's like it that true Oprah is not
coming out and I think I mean we have
the larger be able to watch her over
such a long period of time you see her
progression to becoming much more
comfortable being herself and sharing
that and I think as she shared more
that's what really got like the hard
core audience and that grew so big for
her right that's why her influence
became so powerful is because she was
just honest and true to herself and then
shared that with the world uh uh whereas
you know the people who followed her
that that shock style and she went off
and did something else those guys never
built that following right you just seen
coming on the seed like the latest jab
the latest stabbing the latest whatever
and then they're off to see the next
show where they don't develop that
intense relationship and so I think for
you one for the people watching the way
they get there faster is just have the
confidence to be who you are sooner and
Express that and I know it's hard
because people judge you when you're
going to get hater comments and i know
you do stuff on youtube and there's
always going to be people who hate on
what you're doing and that that can
sting in a bad way to the point we're
like you don't want to do anything
anymore but i think if you have the
skills and you have the ability to make
it a positive impact on the world then
you have the responsibility to do it and
and I know you do you have great talents
and I've seen some of your videos and
you know we've been connected for a
while like joining them all the hangouts
everything um just being more genuine
more you like raw uh your raw self and
trust that people will like that and not
worry about what other people are saying
um that's if you watch Oprah in my
opinion that's the evolution of Oprah
and that's how she build up her audience
so you can do it to your raw self yeah
we let final thing over with I think
with service we absolutely
league but the thing about authenticity
is also vulnerability and I think over
it showing herself I think great leaders
just a very vulnerable at points in time
and that means people gravitate over and
her core mission and values as Evan says
I think you've been consistent right
from the get-go right to now awesome
thank you guys well thanks for calling
in